We know that we can not use the product property to combine either of these
pairs of logs, since remember they have different basis. However, let's try
grabbing our calculator and seeing if we can add them. To add log base 10 of 4
plus natural log of 5. I start out by pressing the log button, since I know
this has an implicit invisible ten down here as a base. You want base 10 of 4
plus natural log, so the ln button of 5. And there we go, we have our number.
Let's write it down. So, according to our calculator, log base 10 of 4 plus
natural log of 5 is about equal to 2.211 so on and so forth. Let's try our
second combination here. So, I've got my calculator all ready, and I just need
to enter log base 2 of 5. But wait, there's no log base 2 button. What am I
going to do? Well, I could use trial and error. But that would be really,
really hard. There must be something easier we can do. Luckily there is.
There's something called changing bases that we can do. What this means is that
we'll convert log base 2 of 5 to something with a different base that we can
evaluate using a calculator. So this is a formula we can use to change a log
from being base a to base b. We have log base a of x equals log base b of x
over log base b of a. This probably feels a little bit confusing right now and
kind of abstract. So, let's try using it to see how it really works. Let's do
this first off with something we know the answer, just to make sure that our
method makes sense. I like us to change log base 2 of 8 to something in base
10. First things first though, what is log base 2 of 8 equal to?